let's consider what we call the window
washer problem what we have is suspended
from some ceiling we have a pulley and
the pulley is suspended by a rope which
we're going to call this string 3 and we
have a rope that is wrapping around this
pulley and then it wraps around another
pulley so this rope is going around
another pulley and it's fixed to the
ceiling and this is what we're gonna
call string 1 and then this string
there's another string that comes down
to a platform and this one we're gonna
call string 2 and sitting on the
platform is a person so we have a person
sitting on the platform and that person
is pulling the rope down now this is a
very complicated problem and it's a
classic example of how do we choose
systems so that we can apply Newton's
second law now one of the important
things we're going to do is learn to see
what when we choose a system what forces
are internal and external and that will
enable us to pick a very nice system
which will make the analysis easy the
way we'll do this is we'll approach it
in stages
well first focus on the person the
platform and this pulley by the way this
is pulley a and this one is pulley B and
let's use the symbol P for the platform
and we'll call this a washer person and
we're going to use the symbol W for the
person so what makes this problem
complicated is all these different
elements now the first stage is that
what we're going to do is we're going to
separately look at the purse
the platform and then combine them into
a system of person and platform but
notice the rope is connected to the
platform so the next stages will also
consider a system consisting of pulley a
person and the platform and the washer
now let's draw the Freebody diagrams
let's begin by drawing the free body
diagram on the washer so washer what do
we have on the washer the first thing to
think about is the string the washer is
pulling the string down so the string is
pulling the washer up so that's a force
of string 1 on the washer now there's
also the gravitational force and washer
G and what we also have to consider the
fact is is that the person is sitting on
the platform so the platform is pushing
the person up and we'll call that a
normal force on the washer due to the
platform and those are the free body
diagram for the free body diagram on the
washer now let's focus on the platform
so here we'll draw the platform and now
let's look at the forces on the platform
let's begin by looking for the internal
forces the the Newton's third law pairs
the platform is pushing the person up
the person is pushing the platform down
so we'll write that for says n on the
platform due to the washer and
immediately let's just circle this third
law pair now string two is pulling the
platform up so let's draw that force we
have we'll call that a tension force in
the string it's on the platform due to
string two and finally we have the
gravitational force on the platform and
that's our free body diagram on the
platform now you may have said well why
should I separate these out why didn't I
just use the person and the platform so
let's draw that picture so now imagine
underneath this you
a system consisting of the person and
the platform and I'll just draw that
system like that so what we're doing is
we're taking these two separate Freebody
diagrams and we're going to combine them
here and by Newton's third law all
internal forces should cancel in pairs
so now let's separately think about the
forces and see that that's the case well
we have the gravitational force on the
system which is the mass of the platform
plus the mass of the washer times G we
still have the string pulling the person
up because the person is pulling the
string down so we still have the force
f1 on the washer that's string 1 on the
washer and we still have the pulley the
tension in string 2 pulling it up so we
still have the force t2 on the platform
now when you look at this what we're
doing is we're adding these two Freebody
diagrams together the internal forces
now are the normal force they're equal
in magnitude opposite and direction so
when you add them together they cancel
and we're just left with that with that
with that and with that and so this is
now the combined system now you might
ask why did we not include the pulley
well let's take a look at that so I'm
gonna draw the Freebody diagram just on
pulley 8 so let's draw a pulley a now
what we have here is the string on both
sides is pulling pulley a up and that's
the tension in string 1 so what we have
is I'm going to call that tension in
string 1 tension in string 1 and just to
alert you that keep in mind that this
force here is the force of the string on
the person and
- is also tension in the string because
this is our sumption of a massless
string so notice that everywhere in a
string the tension is uniform so I'm
just going to simplify that by calling a
t1 what are the other forces on the
pulley well we're assuming that these
pulleys are massless and so there's no
gravitational force on the pulley and
the only thing we have is the string
pulling there's the tension in the
string so now this is a little bit
different this is a force on the pulley
- so at the moment let's do something a
little bit different let's consider our
system to be the string so it's pulley a
we call that string - that's our system
so I modified that a little bit I just
didn't consider the pulley separately I
consider the pulley and the string as
the system then here the string is
pulling the platform up the platform
there for is pulling the string down and
once again we have a third law pair and
so if I added these two together then
what I'll now have and this is why this
problem is kind of complex we have
pulley a string - platform P and washer
person and if we know and these two
systems together we have this
complicated system but what are the
forces on this system
well the Rope is pulling it up the
person was remember we had this force W
one was the force of string one on the
washer that also was the tension
everywhere in the string so we have
another T one up these two forces no
cancel in pairs the internal forces
there and so down we just have mass
platform plus mass of a washer times G
and so you see in this problem if we try
to treat everything separate and I could
have even had the string separate I have
a lot of free body diagrams but when I
think about what's internal and what's
external I can take these two pieces
combine them here internal forces cancel
in pairs
I can draw these two separate systems
again combine them internal forces
cancelling pair and now I have this
pulley a now I can write down Newton's
second law so what I'll do next is I'll
introduce I still have to consider
pulley B I'll use this is my system and
I'll write down Newton's second law and
we'll be able to solve this problem